it's all over and it is one of the most
fantastic victories ever known in Test
cricket history Bob Willis nearly didn't
play in his greatest triumph the
Headingley ashes test of 1981 when he
and Ian both him produced crickets most
improbable comeback even after both them
swashbuckling 149 not out Australia only
had to make a hundred and thirty runs to
win Willis doubtful pre-match because of
illness and knee trouble tore in like a
man possessed he's been listening to
hypnotism tapes beforehand and never
seemed to leave that zone australian
batsman came and went
Willis took 8 wickets England won
captain Mike really believes the
Sunderland born fast bowlers
international career might otherwise
have ended then instead his dodgy knees
both operated on carried him through
three more years and the England
captaincy it is very sad and it's
equally sad that actually the end seemed
to come very quickly last time I saw Bob
was a few weeks ago and he was still
fighting as they say heroically he did
his best to ignore what was happening to
him at this stage he was still on
television up until very recently
they're still very forthright and it
brings to an end in my case a friendship
that has lasted happily for 40 years or
so he became a TV commentator and he's
familiar to modern sky viewers as the
attack dog in studio when England
stumble there should be three sets of
stocks in the town square in Leeds one
for Andy flower one for us to cook a one
for Jonathan trot and a great big barrel
of rotten tomatoes to hurl at them
no offense was taken and Willis's
distinctive bowling run-up was mimicked
more than 30 years on by alistair cooke
allegedly this is an impersonation of
you Bob
allegedly but if you look closely
Charles he shan't charm a great student
of the game and that black and white are
archived back in India and he's quaking
his boots
just at the sight of this action
and the very next ball what happens cook
mops him up and after another ashes
triumph in 2015 and I'm sure the crowds
thoroughly enjoyed it marks out of ten
and four only four well it wasn't about
my game quite a good impression of the
late Brian Clough I thought but young
man when your little purple patch comes
through then I'll have you back in the
job once a bear always a bear I think
Bob beautiful congratulations enjoyed a
recent ceremony to award him a special
Warwickshire County cap and there was
more to him than cricket and TV he was
such a Bob Dylan fan that he added Dylan
to his name by deed poll and a wine
label he launched with Ian Botham
is still going strong many a glass will
be raised around the cricketing world
Nick Powell Sky News